hey 42 here life is full of unbelievable
events of great synchronicity are there
really people whom can predict the
future is there benevolent force at play
or is it simply just the law of large
numbers whatever it is there's no
denying that there have been countless
spookily
accurate predictions made throughout
history
that's half come true let's take a look
at the all-time most amazingly accurate
predictions we start with a woman named
Eleanor Shepard who in 2013 predicted
with a hundred percent accuracy all the
winners of the upcoming Golden Globe
Awards policy Mick is a political and
cultural news website and forum that
launched in 2011 in January 2013 their
culture editor
Eleanor Shepard was assigned to report
on the upcoming Golden Globe Awards she
pulled off an amazing feat of
speculation she accurately predicted
which TV programs and films would take
home each of the 25 awards she got all
25 correct and they weren't no-brainers
Eva
many of the wins were taken by
unexpected nominees On February the 11th
2013 a woman tweeted that her boyfriends
told her about a dream in which the
current Pope Benedict the 16th resigned
and the man named Francesco replaced him
no more than 17 days later and sure
enough Pope Benedict announced his
retirement and Pope Francis took his
place the tweet was in Spanish what the
translation reads my boyfriend woke me
up
last night at 4:00 a.m. saying he had
dreamed of a new pope called Francis the
first and that today Benedict will
reside also just as astonishing in 2010
three years before Pope Francis came
into the spotlight a lawyer named
Christopher Connors registered at the
main name Pope Francis dot-com
when the press asked him why he
registered that the main name he refused
to comment the American TV comedy scrubs
is probably the last place you would
expect to find mind-blowing predictions
about the future but in a 2006 episode
the janitor makes an eerie comment to JD
he said in my opinion we should be
looking for bin Laden in Pakistan sure
enough
five years later US soldiers found bin
Laden hiding in a heavily guarded house
in Pakistan Mark Twain was an American
author but what many people don't know
about him is that he remarkably
predicted the Internet in 1898 Mark
Twain wrote a short story called from
the London Times in 1904 he described an
invention called at electroscope which
used the phone system to create a
worldwide network for sharing
information which is basically the
Internet
keep in mind that he wrote this when
telephones were still very new it is
also written in his story the daily
doings of the globe made visible to
everybody and audibly discussable to by
witnesses separated by any number of
leagues
yep that's right Mark Twain also
predicted social networking but that's
not all that Mark Twain predicted he
also predicted his own death Halley's
Comet is visible from Earth every 75
years mark twain was born in 1835 when
Halley's Comet was visible in the sky
and he predicted that he would die the
next time Halley's Comet was visible
Sherman or he died seventy-five years
later in 1910 joestars
Halley's Comet was visible again next up
is a man who
many of today's modern technologies or
hundred years in advance a relatively
unknown civil engineer John Alfred
Watkins made a number of predictions in
the year 1900 about what the world would
be like in the year 2000 he wrote an
article in a woman's magazine called
Ladies Home Journal entitled what may
happen in the next hundred years his
article began with the words these
prophecies will seem strange almost
impossible he then proceeded to discuss
a handful of future technologies in
great detail most of it was remarkably
accurate here's some of the things he
predicted that came true digital colour
photography mobile phones ready meals
television and tanks here's an
interesting snippet of what he wrote in
his prediction about digital colour
photography photographs will be
telegraphed from any distance if there
be a battle in China a hundred years
hence snapshots of its most striking
events will be published in the
newspapers an hour later photographs
will reproduce all of nature's colors
next up is Robert Heinlein who predicted
the Cold War seven years before it
started
Heinlein was a scientific fiction author
and in 1940 he wrote a short story
called solution unsatisfactory in which
he depicted a United States that
develops a nuclear weapon before the
rest of the world becoming the foremost
superpower and igniting a nuclear arms
race amongst the rest of the world it
was a perfect description of what
happened years later in the events that
led up to the start of the Cold War in
1947 next up and on somewhat of a
similar note English writer HG Wells
predicted the conception of the atomic
bomb 31 years before it was actually
invented
it not an easy task when you consider
the complexity of such an invention in
HG Wells 1914 novel the world set free
Wells wrote about a city destroying
atomic bomb that could explode
continuously using the power of
radioactivity
next up Tanner hoi an American psychic
who claimed to be able to hear spirits
and predict the future during 1995 Hui
was doing a live radio program in North
Carolina when he predicted honor a
deadly terrorist attack against a
Federal Building in Oklahoma City 90
minutes later a bomb was detonated at
the Alfred P murrah Federal Building in
downtown Oklahoma City which killed 168
people it was at the time the worst ever
terrorist attack on US soil in 1949
English novelist George Orwell published
his dystopian novel 1984 which talks
about people being constantly monitored
by closed-circuit security cameras when
the book was first published people
would have quickly dismissed the idea
that CCTV cameras and constant
surveillance would ever be a reality but
as we all know that's not quite how
things panned out we are now what
everywhere we go by CCTV just like in
George Orwell's classic novel ironically
George Orwell's home country England is
now the world's most watched nation the
United Kingdom has one percent of the
world's population but 20% of its CCTV
cameras that's one camera for every 14
people in 2010 the football World Cup
was in full swing and the German octopus
named Paul became an unlikely celebrity
overnight when he correctly predicted
the winners of 11 or
coming World Cup matches Paul lived in a
tank at an aquarium in Germany aquarium
staff put two boxes filled with food
into his tongue each of the flag of a
different country on it
whom we're competing against each other
in an upcoming match Paul would make his
prediction by eating from the box of the
winning team he successfully predicted
the outcomes of 11 of 13 games after the
World Cup finished Paul went on to
successfully predict the outcomes of
basketball and American football games
next off is edgar cayce perhaps one of
the most well known psychics of the 20th
century he earned himself the nickname
the sleeping prophet because he would
deliver psychic readings to people and
make incredibly accurate predictions
whilst in a self-induced hypnotic state
case correctly predicted countless
future events but his most notable
predictions that came true ah he
predicted the collapse of the Soviet
Union the stock market crash and the
Great Depression the rise and fall of
Adolf Hitler and last but not least he
predicted the deaths of not one but two
US presidents Franklin D Roosevelt and
John F Kennedy Australian base Geoffrey
R Palmer is a well-known psychic whose
predictions are somewhat hit and miss
but the handful of correct predictions
he has made have been strikingly
accurate Palmer accurately predicted the
Indian Ocean volcano eruption of
December 26 2004 he also predicted that
Korea was testing nuclear weapons but
his most notable prediction was
correctly predicting the 2005 Hurricane
Katrina that's claimed 1836 lives
next up are the freakishly accurate
predictions of French novelist Jules
Verne he successfully predicted a whole
range of future technologies and events
in his writings such as electric
submarines newscasts and video
conferencing but his most notable
prediction was that of the moon landing
in Verna's 1865 novel from the earth to
the moon which was written over a
hundred years before America's mission
to the moon
Verne described with eerily accurate
detail a space mission to the moon in
Burns story a man's fate it was launched
from Florida in the month of December
both of these facts perfectly aligned
with the real mission over a hundred
years later Verne also managed to
predict the name of the Apollo 11
command module which was named Columbia
and that they would become weightless
once they entered space which he should
not have known at the time which he
wrote the book next up is American
author and inventor Ray Kurzweil he has
made several predictions about future
technologies over the past decades and
an astonishing 86% of them have come
true
whose wheel predicted the fall of the
Soviet Union Computers beating humans at
chess by the year 2000 and wireless
internet becoming widely available in
the 21st century he also predicted
nanotechnology face recognition software
and ebooks Kurzweil has also predicted
that within 15 years from now humans
will crack the code of immortality and
people's lifespans will start rapidly
increasing and finally you can't
possibly talk about this subject without
mentioning the extraordinary michelle de
nostradame more commonly known as simply
Nostradamus
during the 14th century Nostradamus
published over a thousand predictions
for the future and historians have now
deemed that over half of them have come
true he predicted the coming of the
three antichrists in his writings what
he wrote about each Antichrist closely
matches up to the lives of Napoleon
Hitler and Saddam Hussein his writings
about Adolf Hitler included the lines
out of the deepest part of the west of
Europe from poor people a young child
shall be born who with his tongue shall
seduce many people his fame shall
increase in the Eastern Kingdom Hitler
was indeed born to poor parents and used
his tongue to seduce many people to do
his evil bidding Nostradamus
even predicted that Hitler would die
alone
Nostradamus also wrote about an event
that bares extremely close resemblance
to the 911 attacks against America
he wrote the sky will burn at 45 degrees
fire approaches the great new city
experts agree that the great new city at
45 degrees
can only refer to New York City which is
near 45 degrees latitude
Nostradamus also predicted among many
others JFK's assassination the atomic
bomb the French Revolution under the
Great Fire of London thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2